butscher dieser name brennt sich in
unser gedächtnis sowie srebrenica oder
grosny als ort des grauens als die stadt
die den kriegsverbrechen der russischen
armee einen namen gibt diesen
kriegsverbrechen in diesen straßen
bilder die paul ronzheimer unser bild
reporter heute noch einmal dort gemacht
hat den putsch auch heute war er dort
hat diese leichen gesehen von zivilisten
überall menschen in ihren autos
niedergemetzelt
diese bilder zeigen wir ihnen auch weil
es immer noch so viele menschen gibt die
das nicht glauben wollen die von fans
sprechen von lügen nein das ist realität
dass es das was unsere reporter dort
sehen und filmen und so waren wir es
auch mit dieser luftaufnahme hier
gemacht wir zeigen ihnen ein
satellitenfoto dieses satelliten foto
das den friedhof von butscher zeigt und
angeblich soll darauf hier umkreist ein
massengrab zu sehen sein stimmt das paul
ronzheimer ist vor wenigen stunden
dorthin gefahren auf diesem friedhof von
butscher und hat dann das gesehen
meter lange gräben darin plastiksäcke
leichensäcke die toten von butscher
hineingeworfen gestapelt
ich stehe an einem massengrab in butter
ein absolutes schreckensbild direkt an
einer kirche hier wurde eine grube
ausgehoben weil man mit der anzahl der
leichen nicht mehr klar gekommen ist
sowohl soldaten als auch zivilisten
wurden hier begraben sagen uns anwohner
wie viele es sind wer ist ist das alles
wird noch ermittelt teilweise sind die
identitäten nicht klar aber es zeigt den
ganzen horror der sich hier in guca
abgespielt hat
ein kleinstadt friedhof keine ruhestätte
mehr nach diesen kriegsverbrechen dass
die welt aufhört ein massengrab ein
dokument des mordens paar ronzheimer
spricht mit flade schlaf der die toten
von butscher zählt klar ist ob du
sammelst die körper der toten ein wie
viele leichen hast du das jetzt hier in
butter gefunden und jörg größter
dresden 300 leichen er persönlich hat
300 leichen gefunden ist das richtig
ja sehr viele menschen die meisten mit
kopfschüssen die meisten lagen in den
vorgärten ihrer häuser mit den händen
auf dem rücken gefesselt
und dann zeigt flagge auf seine fotos
auf dem handy dokumente des schreckens
bilder die die welt nie vergessen wird
die toten von butscher
[Musik]
priester andré betet für sie
so kommen sie nun nach dem tod ihre
würde zurück
eine messe an
uns haben wir jetzt bei mir bei bild
live am abend eine kleine messe dort am
massengrab für die opfer dieses
kriegsverbrechens können die toten paul
von butscher nach solchen taten jemals
in frieden ruhen
jemals in frieden ruhen
ich glaube nicht dass die menschen in
frieden ruhen können denn das was dort
passiert ist in dieser stadt und heute
hatte ich noch mal viel mehr zeit dort
durchzufahren es ist eine
idyllische stadt einmal gewesen man
sieht so kleine seen schöne häuser und
jetzt wenn man dadurch geht und jeder
gleich auch heute für mich in dieser
straße in der ich war eine verlassene
straße kurz vor butscher dort in den
autos diese zivilisten zu sehen ein
teenager mit seinem vater sehr
wahrscheinlich da waren sport medaillen
in diesem wagen man konnte sich
vorstellen dass der junge vielleicht ein
talentierter fußballer war dort im
lokalen fußballclub dann ein paar
hundert meter weiter ein weiterer
zerschossener wagen da haben wir zwei
senioren gesehen einen alten mann eine
alte frau sehr wahrscheinlich ein
ehepaar die kartoffeln dabei hatten
wieder kartoffel werden uns an das bild
von gestern von dem fahrradfahrer der
niedergeschossen wurde mit kartoffeln
und auch die alten senioren hatten
kartoffeln dabei mir bleibt der satz von
olaf scholz vom bundeskanzler hängender
gestern gesagt hat da muss man jetzt
aufklären müssen experten vom
internationalen roten kreuz hin und
müssen das prüfen müssen das aufklären
was da passiert ist nach dem was du
gesehen hast gibt es überhaupt irgendwas
noch aufzuklären
ich glaube schon dass es eine weitere
untersuchung braucht keinen wir wissen
ja nicht genau wer geschossen hat wessen
auftrag es war wie können davon ausgehen
dass eben die geheimdienstberichte die
julian röpke bereits im dezember
enthüllt hat als er von
massenhinrichtungen geschrieben hat
damals wollte das keiner glauben und hat
gesagt so ein quatsch es würde wladimir
putin ja niemals tun und jetzt sehen wir
dass in den orten in denen die russische
armee kam zivilisten insbesondere männer
gezielt hingerichtet wurden das ist
diese massentötung gab dort wo ich war
haben mir immer wieder anwohner gesagt
dass dort vor allem tschetschenische
kämpfer auch waren was die besondere
brutalität möglicherweise erklärt denn
dafür sind die soldaten aus
tschetschenien bekannt jetzt hat sich
der us präsident joe biden heute dazu
auch geäußert und hat wen wundert's auch
dieses kriegsverbrechen direkt wladimir
putin zu gerechnet er hat gesagt dieser
kerl ist brutal ist es abscheulich was
sind butscher passiert und alle alle
haben es gesehen stellte us-präsident
fest alle haben das gesehen
auch vladimir selensky war dort hat sich
ein bild von der lage gemacht paul auch
ein mann der immer besondere worte
findet welche in diesem moment
er hat so wie vitali klitschko
ebenfalls von einem völkermord
gesprochen von einem genozid der dort
verübt wurde ging das ukrainische volk
und wenn man würde maddie lenski
beobachtet hat in den vergangenen wochen
und monaten dann könnte man ja denken
dass
ihm eigentlich nichts mehr so richtig
etwas anhaben kann aber wenn man ihn
dort sieht in butter in sein gesicht
schaut in seine augen seine emotionen
dann sieht man auch den ganzen schock
des präsidenten über das was er dort
sieht was er dort hört
lasst uns doch einmal über das
politische sprechen was zur gleichen
zeit gerade passiert oder nicht passiert
wären es gerade schon kurz eingeblendet
gesehen das sind harte sätze aus polen
aus warschau von polens regierungschef
matthäus morawski der harte kritik übt
den angesichts dieser kriegsverbrechen
von butscher sagt er jeder der die
mitschriften also die protokolle ließ
der wird wissen dass deutschland die
größte bremse ist wenn es um noch
entschiedenere sanktionen geht
das ist schwer auszuhalten wenn das soll
ist
ja das ist schwer auszuhalten als
deutscher kann vor allem wenn man als
deutscher hier steht in kiel wenn man an
zwei tagen hintereinander in butter war
und unzählige leichen gesehen hat dann
fragt man sich was muss denn noch
passieren dass unsere politik dort
einlenkt das nicht weiter blockiert wird
was sanktionen angeht jetzt muss man
vielleicht erklären polen war schon sehr
viel früher für schärfere sanktionen
polen hat natürlich auch besondere sorge
dass man als nächstes dran sein könnte
sozusagen wenn putin hier in der ukraine
erfolgreich würde das ist ja das was
eben in polen viele viele fürchten von
daher dort auch die besondere tonalität
ich glaube dass auch mit den grünen in
der regierung mit robert habeck und
annalena baerbock jetzt mehr druck
passieren könnte auch auf olaf scholz
wobei man sagen muss das nein zum gas
und öl embargo das kam ja auch von
robert habeck der gesagt hat ja das wird
schwierig und sich zunächst dagegen
ausgesprochen hat du hast es jetzt
werden wir sprechen immer wieder gesagt
du bist heute noch mal dorthin gefahren
nachdem die gestern von dort aus
butscher direkt berichtet hast uns
bilder mitgebracht hast die uns schon
haben kaum schlafen lassen heute also
mich hat das tatsächlich in meinen
träumen heute verfolgt hast du nicht
einen gedanken gehabt nach dem gestrigen
tag und gesagt da will ich da kann ich
nie wieder hin
nein denn ich sehe es als meine pflicht
an meine aufgabe so wie viele andere
kollegen auch hier weiter zu berichten
und es zeigt sich dass es dort ganz
viele menschen gibt deren geschichte
gehört werden muss heute die interviews
mit augenzeugen waren andere als die die
wir gestern geführt haben und wir hoffen
dass wir auch morgen wieder dorthin
zurück können denn es gibt dort sehr
sehr schaurige berichte und es gibt auch
berichte darüber was mit einzelnen
zivilisten passiert ist die ja auf die
druck gemacht wurde dass sie dort raus
gehen sollten richtung russland da sind
überall dinge über die wir noch reden
müssen über die berichtet werden musste
und die recherchiert werden müssen danke
dafür dass sind dokumente die auch
juristische folgen noch mal irgendwann
haben werden haben können danke dir paul
erst recht weil die russische seite
behauptet das ist alles fake das ist
alles so gar nicht passiert danke für
das gespräch mit dir